[Music]
nicolai thanks I'm a huge fan of Game of
Thrones like so many people and just
thrilled that you could be here that's
great for you in it the one thing I've
noticed as a fan of the show
is that you went in the first season
you're constantly you're wearing golden
armor all the time you look perfect
lately you're constantly covered in mud
and that seemed we just showed then this
is a picture of you just after getting a
shooting a scene hook like this all the
time on the show no when is this going
to stop
I don't know but the thing is we're
shooting in in in Belfast in Northern
Ireland and it is it is the wettest
place in Europe yeah and there was one
thing I came to set and I it might have
been that day and the director Alice
graves is waiting for me and he's
standing from this this pool of mud and
I go wow that's looks nice and so no
it's not done yet and they called props
over they just started holding for 10
minutes and it was just it was muddy
beyond belief and then and then they
tell you then you just dive in and they
almost being beaten up that day all day
and actually at the end of the day I
think he felt bad and he was like in you
know where the proofs and all that so he
kind of snuck down next to me any guy
you okay you sure and I said yeah fine
get away Alex yeah but then you go get
back to your trailer you you get out of
your costume and you find I mean I had
mud so far my crack goes well I'm not a
fan anymore
I just want to give you visuals yeah I
know who's interesting is that I would
think he'd be jealous because there are
different lands in Game of Thrones and
there's this other land where other
actors shoot that I believe is the
Mediterranean yeah every shot is them in
Bermuda
you know dolphins feeding them grapes
and you're being dragged around the mud
of Belfast not fair is it
no but you have the executive producers
they would travel because we have
several crews working and there's one
crew in Croatia which is just a
beautiful beautiful place Dubrovnik and
they will come back and they will
complain about you know running out of
Sun lotion and I'll just yeah that's
great guys I I've got mud up my ass I
made this observation recently and other
people noticed it too that your
character looks a lot like or did before
we got money like Prince Charming in
Shrek the I think we have it here it's
an amazing
exact same hair that's it
that was my inspiration when yeah as an
actor you said this is who I want to
channel